bonjour france hongrie bellamy bonjour
pas seulement candidat tête de liste des
républicains européenne mais évidemment
philosophe tu es chrétien un vous
l'assumez le revendique et donc votre
présence est d'autant plus intéressante
ce matin le moment là j'ai envie de dire
le temps s'est arrêté
on sait qu hier soir mais elles
maquereau a renoncé à son allocution
solennelle devant les français il devait
annoncer les mesures faites au grand
débat et vous même vous avez suspendu
votre campagne et annuler le meeting
était prévue ce soir à nîmes pour lancer
officiellement la campagne républicain
bien sûr nous sommes tous profondément
bouleversés par ces images l'image de
l'effondrement de ce trésor inestimable
dont nous sommes les héritiers et au
fond ce qui est profondément frappant
c'est que nous vivons tous je crois
collectivement ce moment commun comme un
deuil comme si nous étions en train de
de perdre quelque chose de nous mêmes de
voir disparaître une part de ce que nous
sommes
évidemment il faudra à se tourner vers
l'avenir évidemment il faudra
reconstruire mais aujourd'hui il faut
laisser le temps à cette souffrance que
nous éprouvons et à ce moment qui nous
rassemble aussi d'une certaine manière
et il y a dans le fait que nous nous
sentions rassemblés dans la tristesse
quelque chose aussi d'une espérance
on a vu ces images hier soir
l'effondrement de la flèche et on a tous
pensé à quelque chose dont on n'ose pas
parler non en parlait ce matin c'est
évidemment l'effondrement des tours de
new york le 11 septembre
évidemment ça n'a rien à voir l'origine
n'est absolument pas on l'espère mais
certainement rien à voir avec ce qui
s'est passé là-bas mais de voir ce
symbole de la verticalité ce symbole
d'un monde ces symboles de puissance
tout d'un coup disparaître dans les
flammes
instantanément vous avez raison ça n'a
rien à voir aussi en ce sens que
précisément il n'ya pas d'abord de
drames humains et on peut dire un
immense merci aux pompiers qui ont
bataillé toute la nuit pour sauver ce
grand trésor on peut adresser notre
pensée à ce pompier qui je crois a été a
été blessé dans cette opération
mais au fond ce que nous voyons malgré
tout c'est qu'en effet et c'est sans
doute le point commun il y a quelque
chose de cette verticalité qui s'élève
vers le ciel
cette verticalité en particulier dans le
cas de notre dame de
rick est un élan vers le ciel un élan
vers ce qu'il y a un an nous de plus
élevé et qui d'un seul coup se trouve à
terre et en voyant s'effondrer cette
flèche je pense que nous avons tous eu
le coeur retourné devant ces images
éprouvante entendu des cris des
parisiens dans la rue en voyant cette
c'est devant cette flèche ces fonds ont
fait pas seulement les parisiens en
effet c'est magnifique de voir cet élan
de solidarité qui s'exprime partout à
travers le monde
anvers ce ce moment envers ce peuple
français qui est évidemment touché dans
ce qu'il a de plus de plus précieux et
au fond ce qui est fondamental c'est de
se dire que cette aspiration vers ce
qu'il y a un an nous de plus haut
c'est sans doute cela qu'il faut
retrouver et ce moment en particulier
exige de nous aussi une forme de hauteur
en tous les cas il exige de nous que
nous puissions être de nouveau à la
hauteur de cet héritage que nous avons
en commun
alors cette auteure elle était partagée
par l'ensemble de la classe politique et
j'ai envie de dire c'est tant mieux ça
me rend un peu parfois un peu dérisoire
nos querelles quotidiennes on a vu de
jean-luc mélenchon à marine le pen en
passant évidemment par françois hollande
ou nicolas sarkozy l'a même stupéfaction
qui a saisi toute la classe politique
qui s'est retrouvé autour de ce symbole
de notre notre nation symbole d'histoire
est le symbole de paris symbole de la
france selon les dires du monde parce
que non seulement les dirigeants
français mon avis même donald trump
barack obama immédiatement se mettre aux
côtés du peuple français
bien sûr au fond il aura fallu peut-être
cet événement pour re découvrir que
notre dame de paris et au au point zéro
des routes de france c'est de là que
partent toutes les routes de notre pays
et toutes les indications kilométrique
c'est aussi bien sûr vers notre dame de
paris que convergent chaque année des
dizaines de millions de visiteurs qui
viennent découvrir ce que notre culture
a apporté au monde et nous ne devons pas
à dire cela pour en être fier vous
parliez tout à l'heure de 2,7 hors ue27
puissance mais je crois que ce que nous
contemplons aujourd'hui c'est d'abord le
spectacle déchirant de ce qu'il y à
d'infiniment beau dans cette
civilisation que nous recevons et dont
nous avons
à transmettre l'essentiel mais c'est
aussi le caractère infiniment émouvant
de son infinie fragilité et redécouvrir
le sens de cette fragilité s'est re
découvrir que cet héritage nous engage
bien sûr que la classe politique
s'émeuvent d'une seule voix c'est
légitime et nécessaire et c'est beau
même mais maintenant ceci doit
constituer aussi l'occasion d'une action
plus plus responsable envers notre
patrimoine
aujourd'hui c'est le spectacle de notre
dame de paris monuments emblématiques
qui brûle mais parfois malheureusement
dans l'indifférence et dans le silence
ce sont des dizaines d'églises qui sont
atteintes par l'érosion par l'usure qui
sont abîmés qui se délabre au milieu de
chacune de nos villes de chacun de nos
villages et depuis le début de cette
campagne je vois beaucoup de maires dans
beaucoup de petites villes de france
dans l'eau beaucoup de villages de
france qui disent qu'ils n'ont pas les
moyens qu'ils n'ont plus les moyens
qu'ils sont seuls face à à la tâche que
constitue l'entretien de ceux de ce
patrimoine vient sa chaude si nous
sommes solidaires aujourd'hui dans le
deuil sachant aussi demain être
solidaire dans l'action pour faire en
sorte que nous puissions offrir aux
générations qui viendront ce que nous
avons à leur transmettre
alors justement ce matin en apnée idée
plus précise de ce qui était endommagée
avec notamment ces images que vous allez
voir de l'intérieur de l'église on a cru
hier soir que que peut-être que tout
allait être détruit on est rassuré ce
matin la structure pour l'instant tient
les premiers nous disent qu'elles
devraient tenir et on voit que
finalement la voûte n'a été que
partiellement endommagé au fond c c'est
plutôt la structure la charpente et le
plomb qui s'est effondré quand on l'a vu
ces images hier de drones
on a l'impression que l'ensemble de la
cathédrale était en feu quand on regarde
les images à l'intérieur
ce matin on voit que quasiment toute la
voûte a été préservé au fond que la
charpente s'est effondré sur la goutte
on voit simplement ce trou béant
d'ailleurs quand on la regarde et on
sent tout à l'heure on se demandait
c'était une vraie photo pour ça que les
bellamy
il ya quelque chose d'irréel à avoir ces
images se demande si on est en train de
faire un cauchemar
en même temps dans cet incroyable
solidité de ceux de ce monument il ya
quelque chose comme le sourire de ceux
qui l'ont construit au cours des siècles
le sourire de ceux qui nous montre
l'incroyable virtuosité de leur savoir
faire
leur art cette charpente qui datait du
xiiie siècle
cette charpente du xiiie siècle dont les
chaînes n'avaient jamais été remplacés
elle tenait encore et la voûte avec cet
art si singulier de la clé de voûte qui
peut faire tenir ensemble vers le haut
vers le ciel des pierres qui sont
suspendus dans l'air et bien ce miracle
la tient encore et je crois que au fond
c'est peut-être cela qu'il faut retenir
aussi nous avons à recevoir ce
savoir-faire à nous montrer à la hauteur
de cette exigence architectural
extraordinaire qui fait tenir depuis
huit siècles ce bâtiment au milieu de
l'île de la cité
mais nous avons aussi à faire tenir les
clés de voûte qui font que nous sommes
ensemble une société que nous sommes
ensemble une civilisation tout ce qui
fait que dans ce moment si particulier
de notre histoire qui sans doute
s'exprime aussi à travers ces images
nous avons le sentiment que ce que nous
avons de plus précieux et menacé de se
défaire et ans avoir retrouvé les clés
de voûte qui nous tiennent ensemble qui
est sans aucun doute le défi
profondément politique que nous avons
devant nous là on va reparler de ça
parce que ce lien vous faites entre
l'événement qui est survenu hier et
puisque le sens de votre engagement
politique au fond encore comme des
nouvelles de ce qui s'est passé cette
nuit il semblerait qu'une grande partie
du trésor et des oeuvres d'art était
sauvée parce que des procédures qui sont
prévues par les monuments historiques en
cas d'incendié à une chaîne humaine qui
a relié avec des policiers des
militaires et les employés de la mairie
de paris et du diocèse notre dame à
l'hôtel de ville et on a transféré le
trésor par exemple il ya un clou et de
la croix du christ qui est dans le 13h
notre dame le aussi la couronne d'épinés
tous ces objets auraient été sauvés il
semble effectivement que c'est jeu ces
objets ont pu être ont pu être sauvés et
on doit dire là encore notre infinie
reconnaissance envers les les pompiers
de paris envers tous les sapeurs
pompiers des départements
d'ile-de-france qui ont été engagés pour
mener cette opération
parce que ces objets sont aussi
l'héritage de notre histoire c'est la
tunique de saint louis qui a ramené
effectivement en france
ces objets si précieux qui pour beaucoup
de croyants pour beaucoup de chrétiens
ont une signification profonde et qui
sont encore une fois au coeur de paris
au coeur de notre capitale le symbole de
ceux de ce coeur battant de cette vie
qui se transmet et je crois que le fait
que cette chaîne humaine que cet élan de
solidarité que cette ingéniosité dans
l'action oc est permis de le sauver ses
trésors est aussi une joie dans le deuil
que nous pouvons partager ce matin ce
moment est très particulier aussi parce
que nous sommes à l'orée de la semaine
sainte
c'est à dire de ce moment ci si fort
dans l'année pour les chrétiens qui se
remémore le fait que à travers la mort
la vie peut passer à travers le mal la
grâce peut surabondé et c'est aussi ce
que nous voyons dans cet élan de
solidarité qui se manifeste dans ces
trésors de générosité dans les risques
pris avec tant de dévouement par ceux
qui se sont engagés pour sauver ce qui
devait l'être
c'est peu commun de voir un homme
politique que vous êtes aujourd'hui
parler de cette manière de de la semaine
sainte et qu'est ce qu'elle représente
qu'elle incarne pour pour pour les
chrétiens cette envie de dire cette
double appartenance
vous vous l'a revendiquée et vous vous
l'affirmez en politique je suis chrétien
et je sais ce n'est pas un mystère j'ai
été suffisamment parfois critiqué où on
me l'a parfois suffisamment reproché
mais je n'en ai jamais fait un étendard
politique
ce que je crois aujourd'hui c'est au
fond nous voyons quelque chose de très
beau et de très fort vous avez une
famille nous le vivons tous se
retrouvent dans le deuil
quand elle perd un être cher même malgré
les divisions malgré les déchirures qui
peuvent toucher toute famille est au
fond nous voyons bien qu'aujourd'hui
c'est toute la france qui se retrouve au
chevet de notre dame de paris
et ça n'est pas une question d'être
croyant ou de ne pas être croyant notre
héritage chrétien n'appartient pas aux
chrétiens il appartient à tous les
français et tous les français doivent
eux se sentir légitime descendants de
ceux qui ont construit notre dame de
paris et doivent se sentir les d'une
certaine manière les enfants de cet acte
de foi qui a fait se dresser vers le
ciel ses deux flèches que nous avons vu
s'effondrer
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on soit pour être
franc c'est obligé d'être croyant bien
traire ça veut dire simplement que au
fond nous le voyons bien dans ce débat
parfois si absurde autour des racines
chrétiennes de l'europe des racines de
notre civilisation
on en est arrivé parfois une forme de
déni de réalité jusqu'à nier ce qui
avait fait notre histoire nous sommes
rappelés à cette réalité par le fait que
tous nous sommes tous saisis dans nos
tripes
nous sommes à temps dans notre coeur
devant ces images là comme si au fond
elle venait nous rappeler que que nous
en ayons conscience ou non nous sommes
les enfants de cette histoire et nous
avons à faire de cette histoire
l'occasion de prolonger dans l'avenir
ce magnifique élan dont nous avons
hérité nous avons à faire de ses racines
le chemin par où passera la sève dont
nous aurons besoin pour reconstruire
notre société alors c'est un peu ce qu'a
dit aussi le présent la république hier
soir en tout cas il a dit que dès
aujourd'hui on reconstruire est notre
dame on écoute emmanuel macron cette
cathédrale nous la rebâtir ont tous
ensemble et c'est sans doute une part du
destin français
et le projet que nous aurons pour les
années à venir mais je m'y engage une
souscription nationale sera lancée et
bien au-delà de nos frontières
une souscription nationale va donc être
lancée et aux doors et bien on l'a pris
à la famille pinault a décidé d'allouer
100 millions d'euros pour la
reconstitution notre-dame et on a vu
beaucoup de messages dans le monde
entier de gens qui sont prêts à nous
aider à aider la france à reconstruire à
rebâtir notre dame oui c'est magnifique
de voir cet élan de générosité qui
s'exprime pour ma part je crois comme le
président de la république je lui suis
reconnaissant de cet appel qu'il a lancé
qu'il faut bien sûr s'engager dans la
reconstruction de notre dame de paris
parce que paris a besoin de notre dame
de paris et que la france a besoin de
devoir reconstruire ce ce lieu fort de
notre histoire ce lieu disons le aussi
qui est si fort au coeur de notre
culture c'est c'est bien sûr tant de
moments forts de l'histoire de france
rendent deuil tant de gloire temps de
deuil le bourdon qui résonne à chaque
fois qu'il est pression' république
aussi regarder le général de gaulle qui
était qui a été inhumé en 1970 en 1970
dans la cathédrale pompidou 84 ans plus
tard mêmes
même françois mitterrand il y avait une
cérémonie d'hommage à françois
mitterrand en janvier 97 dans la
cathédrale notre dame est effectivement
bien au delà et bien avant cette
histoire ce sont tant de rois de france
tant d'anonymes aussi qui sont passés
par ces parcelles cathédrale qui nous a
été légué d'ailleurs par des artistes
qui ne nous ont pas pour beaucoup
d'entre eux donner leur nom c'est
l'histoire de beaucoup de français qui
passent par ce lieu beaucoup de nos
histoires personnelles aussi est au fond
on voit bien comme dans cet élan de
solidarité se manifeste en effet le
désir de continuer cette histoire qui
nous a précédés et qui doit durer après
nous et je crois que au fond nous devons
prendre la mesure de ce que peut être ce
moment ce moment qui doit nous réveiller
à ce qu'il fait précisément ce trésor
magnifique que nous avons dans les mains
sont infinies vulnérabilité parce qu'au
fond ce n'est pas seulement notre dame
qui brûle nous sommes la génération la
première génération qui voit notre dame
se défaire
sous ses yeux notre dame de paris brûle
et nous devons être si la génération qui
effectivement reconstruire non seulement
cette cathédrale mais qui reconstruira
aussi effectivement ce qui fait le lien
qui unit tous les français et jérôme
fourquet a publié il ya quelques jours
un un texte très important je crois qui
s'appelle la france archipel dans lequel
il décrit une france qui n'est plus
qu'une addition de communautés qui se
juxtaposent les unes aux autres sans se
reconnaître un lien commun et bien
aujourd'hui nous sommes rappelés à la
force de ce lien commun évidemment d'une
manière brutale mais au fond ce réveil
malgré tout peut être fécond s'il nous
entraîne à reconstruire maintenant à
rebâtir ce qui doit l'être pour que
notre société puisse se savoir de
nouveaux liés on le voit au fond après
l'attentât qui a touché la france après
le crime de mohamed merah les français
se sont rendus en masse à notre dame de
paris
exactement comme il l'avait fait dans
tant de moments de leur histoire
il faut que nous sachions de nouveaux
quelles sont nos lieux communs quel est
notre lien commun que nous sachions de
nouveaux reconstruire ce vers quoi nous
pourrons nous tourner pour rester unis
ensemble ça c'est la tâche que à
laquelle vous êtes à clé dans le cas de
la campagne des européennes notamment en
portant cette sensibilité des
républicains n'est pas partagée au
départ par tous les républicains mais on
voit dans les sondages par don de
revenir à une réalité plus prosaïque
ça frémit votre votre score dans les
européennes est encore loin de celui de
françois fillon au premier tour de la
présidentielle mais vous avez grappiller
quelques points vous êtes à sale selon
les articles surnage à 13% 14 % parfois
est ce que l'on ressent quoique on se
dit que peut-être vous êtes en train de
réussir à sortir les républicains de
l'ornière tout cela paraît bien bien peu
de chose à l'égard de ce que nous vivons
d'abord c'est vrai que ce travail de
transmettre c'est d'abord mon engagement
professionnel moi je n'avais pas pensé à
être engagés aujourd'hui dans cette
campagne je suis d'abord un professeur
un enseignant qui tente de transmettre
non pas un patrimoine matériel mais un
patrimoine immatériel qui est
fondamental aussi pour l'avenir d'une
civilisation pour l'avenir d'une société
est aujourd'hui nous le voyons bien dans
ce débat des européennes ce qui est en
jeu c'est aussi notre inquiétude devant
le devenir d'une civilisation tout
entière moi le travail que j'essaye de
faire très simplement avec toute une
famille politique avec avec tous les
républicains c'est de tenter
effectivement
d'offrir aux français un choix qui leur
permettra demain de reconstruire de
préserver ce qui doit l'être de le
transmettre et de reconstruire aussi
pour pouvoir nous tourner vers l'avenir
c'est bien sûr le défi culturel c'est
aussi le défi écologique c'est aussi le
défi économique parce que nous avons le
sentiment que se perd sur tous ces
terrains là la capacité que nous aurons
demain de continuer de rayonner de
continuer de vivre ensemble et c'est
très court d'une même si l'innovation et
c'est très compliqué parce qu'on voit
bien avec la mondialisation la
globalisation vous parliez du
communautarisme tout à l'heure la
difficulté de savoir ce qu'est la france
aujourd'hui quelle est l'identité
française
mais on n'a jamais eu autant besoin de
nommer ce que nous sommes la france ce
n'est pas en désignant son identité
l'occasion d'une fermeture à l'altérité
au contraire c'est en sachant de nouveau
reconnaître notre culture en sachant la
nommer en sachant retrouver justement à
notre dame de paris aussi bien claudel
que peggy en sachant retrouver ce qui a
fait notre histoire commune ce qui a
forgé notre langue ce qui a fait notre
art et notre vision du monde que nous
pourrons je le crois profondément aussi
répondre et relever le défi de
l'intégration tant de jeunes qui
grandissent en france ne savent pas
parce que nous n'avons pas su leur dire
ce que signifie être français
à quelle histoire ils peuvent participer
désormais et je crois qu'encore une fois
il ne s'agit pas de se replier dans le
passéisme de se refermer dans une
histoire figé mais nous le voyons bien
tous aujourd'hui encore une fois il
s'agit de retrouver ce que nous avons en
commun pour nous projeter dans l'avenir
en nous appuyant sur cet élan magnifique
que nous recevons de tous ceux qui nous
ont précédés et ça c'est votre défi aux
élections européennes et plus
généralement pour de famille politique à
laquelle nous désormais vous appartenez
et plus généralement pour tous les
français bien sûr mais singulièrement
pour cette famille politique est
effectivement la famille politique des
républicains qui est l'héritière aussi
d'une sensibilité où on m'a souvent
qualifié de conservateur j'ai toujours
dit que ce mot ne suffisait sans doute
pas à résumer tous les défis qui sont
devant nous mais peu importe au fond
nous voyons bien que nous avons quelque
chose à préserver quelque chose à
transmettre
et oui c'est vrai que nous devons sans
doute avoir à nous retrouver aujourd'hui
devant ce défi fondamental mais